he was lucky juan ramon Rojo Gonzalez
did not expect to save her such views
for another 8 years 10 months ago the
etta militant was released early for
good behavior after serving 21 years of
his sentence many of his former fighters
should also be in line for early parole
but Spain is using a legal trick to try
to prevent it espana the Spanish state
has disregarded the law in order to keep
the pressure up it is just another
repressive measure which they used to
unfairly extend prison terms them into a
person the issue has roiled the public a
life sentence is 30 years regardless of
the severity of the actual crime this at
a terrorist was ordered to serve more
than 3,000 years and the state wanted to
deduct her good behavior from that
number not from the legal 30 years she
appealed at the European Court of Human
Rights and one look at this humble go it
highlights the problems the Spaniards
have with their own democracy OPM Olivia
and it also shows that there is a
political fight that has not yet been
resolved that individual will Rojo
Gonzalez was sent down for committing
several murders in the name of Basque
separatists his last crime was the
shooting of two young men in Arun
one of the brothers died the other got
away he says he no longer sees killing
as the answer he believes in the
ceasefire agreed by Etta and Spain two
years ago even though Etta remains
committed to bask independence it was ok
cielo is fear me the step is decisive
the armed struggle in this country is
over we are now trying to find a
political solution to the conflict a
solution which recognizes the rights of
this country the Basque Country this
debate Spinelli for many relatives of
the victims that sounds like mockery 28
years ago today said the as badas father
was killed in a terrorist attack she's
stunned that the government may have to
release more than 50 members of etta at
once and wishes lawmakers had made the
legislative changes that could have
prevented the current situation after
mucho tiempo fully devoted by Spanish
politicians should have changed the law
a long time ago it would have made sense
to do it during the years when Etta was
most active but it didn't happen okay I
said I know Sonya and gate that sits in
my life every time a terrorist is set
free her thoughts turned to her father
Carlos Diaz was chief of police in the
Basque Country and Lieutenant Colonel in
the spanish military that's what made
him a target for Etta
a BF time in FL I knew he had received
threats earlier yeah but he didn't want
to leave the Basque Country he came from
Bilbao like all of us and he wanted to
be here to defend democracy in the
constitutional state of Spain tolerated
by then he was killed here in the suburb
of vitoria the bass capital on the 7th
of March 1985 he did what he did every
day and stopped at a gas station for
breakfast on his way to work while he
was inside a bomb was attached to his
car and when he started the ignition it
exploded
collectively etta terrorists have killed
more than 800 people more than 300 cases
remain unsolved Carlos Diaz assassin has
never been caught looking I mean
personalmente macau sighs I'm very
disappointed in my country and what I
would like most is to leave I don't feel
it's pain the country for which my
father gave His life either supports or
represents me that is a gross injustice
for my father but it gave me bad so many
other victims yeah me buddy thank that's
what I'm eating Bravo Gonzalez was
caught and spent half of his life in
jail he favors the peace process but he
rejects the Spanish government's call
for an official at apology he says he
was a soldier
zukoski antenna momento en que a
shawarma minotdental moment you become
an activist you know you are going to
cause damage the former parthen you are
aware of your responsibility from the
moment you join the struggle pero yo no
confio que el hecho de camila tante unos
militant a but asking for remorse is not
a solution de una manera concrete ax
soluciona
while the strasbourg verdict is a
victory for Etta it's a slap in the face
for the relatives of victims and it's
not the end of the ongoing debate
you